and battles about the different battles
of the city of course in an air that
kills David McCumber tells the story of
the employees of the sauna light factory
and Libby Montana who along with other
residents of the city are suffering from
as best as poisoning he spoke about it
recently for 40 minutes portions of this
program contain language that some may
find offensive tonight university
bookstore is very pleased to welcome
peel surprise winner David McCumber
managing editor at the seattle
post-intelligencer to talk about he and
former p I reporter Andrew Schneider's
book and air the kills how asbestos poet
at the asbestos poisoning of Libby
Montana uncovered a national scandal for
60 years the grace corporation blanketed
a small Montana town in a poison dust
sickening a significant number of its
own citizens and all of it would have
remained covered up had it not been for
the investigative work of them cumbridge
Schneider in air that kills is an expose
of corporate negligence and example of
the Free Press at its most relevant and
vital to our lives please welcome David
McCumber that's good I think thank you
thank you very much Matthew and thank
you to university bookstore for for
having me here I'd like to correct the
record quickly I'm not a Pulitzer Prize
winner my partner my co-author Andrew
Schneider is a double Pulitzer Prize
winner I was a finalist for one but
that's as close as I ever got i also
just have a couple of other quick
thankies to make I seen this how I'm
reading reading in my hometown I have to
thank the newspaper i work for the
seattle post-intelligencer for the
commitment that they made to allow us to
pursue this story it's an uncommon
commitment in this day and age this
story took 16 months and a great deal of
of reporting work and expense and I'm
proud of the pi/4 for doing that I'm
also greatly indebted to Andy Schneider
my my co-author can't be here tonight
unfortunately I lost him to the st.
Louis post-dispatch he's an amazing
journalist and people have asked me
about taking on projects like this and
my advice is if you're going to write a
piece of journalism like this try to do
it with a two-time Pulitzer Prize winner
collaboration is never easy but having a
reporter of Andy's caliber certainly is
a great thing I'm going to read the
prologue to this book because I think it
says what this books about I hope as
well as I can say it and then I'll be
happy to take some questions and and any
conversation that you guys would like to
indulge in the single lodgepole pine
from what's left of zona light mountain
would be plenty fell it watch out for
the cloud of dust skidded out peel it
rip it into one by fours and sell it to
a survivor of the plague on this place
it doesn't take much lumber to knock
together 200 simple crosses take them to
the body shop prime them spray them
white paint a name in black on each one
that's probably enough for this year if
you don't look too hard into the past
for more names after all for six decades
not one doctor put the actual words on a
death certificate in Libby Montana
asbestos-related disease but now you're
at it don't stop making crosses the
little town of Libby will be needing two
or three thousand more the federal
government came in and did the biggest
public health survey in its history a
third of the town got what gala
Benefield accurately calls the death
sentence mincing words is not her style
the town already knows many of the names
that will need to be painted miners sure
some of them men who actually dug to
death out of the mountain hauled it
milled it swept its act it breathed it
for two or three bucks an hour and glad
to do it then we're at home on their
clothes ma'am like less scram stad
here's the hard thing many of the miners
are already gone and most of the names
still to be painted are those of their
wives and children and grandchildren
still others on the list have no family
connection no way to know exactly where
or when they inhaled enough of the dust
that covers Libby to lodge tiny fibers
of tremolite asbestos into their lungs
to start the inexorable process of
inflammation pleural thickening loss of
lung function fluid buildup and slow
suffocation some who might in some
obscene way be considered lucky will go
more quickly from lung cancer or
mesothelioma a fancy name for another
kind of death sentence a cancer of the
lining of the lung death followed the
vermiculite or from zona light mountain
as closely as the asbestos fibers that
contaminated it followed it far from
Libby all across the country to more
than 300 processing plants and farther
yet today in millions of homes the
hazardous material still rests and
attics and walls to be sent into air and
lungs with any disturbance asbestos from
Libby was released into the air in New
York City when the World Trade Center
buildings collapsed nobody knows how
many people have died from it or where
or how many more will die hundreds of
thousands more people will be exposed to
asbestos from other sources in this
country from breaks from contaminated
talc from other sources from iron ore
from all the products containing
asbestos that are still being legally
manufactured and sold because of the
power of an industry here and in Canada
that has lied and covered up for a
deadly century and because of a
government that has not protected us its
workers and consumers in Libby even as
the Environmental Protection Agency
struggles to clean up the toxic mess
some unknown number of the kids who show
no sign of illness now as they ride
their bikes down quiet streets or crowd
boisterously into the pizza
Hut after a ballgame will die the same
way that's what breaks less scrams dad's
heart and what makes gala benefield
madder than a stepped-on snake strong is
a good word to describe gala picture
Nordic blonde hair fighting the grey and
an attractive functional cut and an
expressive mouth equally comfortable
with a smile a kiss or a swear word I
can say [ __ ] you without moving my lips
she says sweetly pushing her glasses up
with an extended middle finger her blue
eyes betray a quickness of thought and
twinkle as a natural state of affairs
but go cold as Libyan februari when the
subject turns to asbestos for good
reason she lost her mother and father to
libby's curse now she and her husband
David are diagnosed with the disease 62
members of their family have either died
of the disease had been diagnosed or
remain at high risk gala was one of the
first to fight in court to get the WR
grace company owner of the vermiculite
mine with asbestos in the or to be found
responsible for the dying after
achieving that she has never stopped
fighting for the victims and their
families not for an instant at 67 less
scram stad is still trim wasted and
muscular and he still plays country
music around town as he has for 40 years
after he was diagnosed with asbestosis
in 1996 he became the first former miner
to take grace to trial and win but that
won't keep him alive since his trial he
has learned that his wife nor Rita and
two of their children have the same
disease that will kill him I loved my
job at zona light he says quietly each
of his shortening breaths as a gold coin
to be spent wisely and so he's very
soft-spoken even when his jaw sets and
you can see the pain in his eyes I loved
it so much that even if they had told me
I was endangering my life I would
probably have stayed but if they told me
was killing my wife and my family too I
would have run like hell on this day
Memorial Day 2001 gala and less put
aside their anger and concentrated on
honoring the victims this year for the
first time there was to be a public
remembering an acknowledgement of the
many who have died from asbestos that
loan was an enormous thing for a town
that had suffered in silence for so long
a town literally left to die by every
branch of every government charged with
making sure something like this does not
happen a town that for so many years
either did not know or did not
acknowledge what was killing so many by
now the truth was out unavoidable people
around the world knew about the dying in
Libby and so it was only right some of
the survivors decided that the dead
should be honored two men led this
effort Mike Switzer has been diagnosed
with asbestosis his was one of the first
families to settle in Libby more than a
century ago Jim Roscoe has been
diagnosed with asbestosis so have two of
his brothers and his sister his effort
is most ironic his second cousin mark
was governor of Montana when the dying
became public knowledge in 1999 mock
Roscoe made concerned noses and did
nothing of substance many of his former
neighbors in Libby say bitterly Mike
Switzer regime Rosco got the materials
for the crosses donated they were built
in Libby high school shop class the
painting was done at jeans body shop and
Stephanie berry volunteered to paint the
names some of the local real estate
outfits and others of the Chamber of
Commerce were little nervous about
putting the crosses where they'd be
visible to everybody they talked about
putting them behind the chamber offices
out of the way Mike Switzer even got a
phone call or two what are you trying to
do to our town gala went to the city
council once suggested it would be a
good idea to put the crosses of the
cemetery where so many people from the
town of becoming for Memorial Day the
cemetery rests in bottom land not far
off highway 2 behind the venture in look
down and you'll see a serene sea of
grass and marble somehow uniquely
Montanan alum Luis Kendall born august
3rd 1936 died September first 1998 is
laid to rest beneath the epitaph one
hell of a man illustrated by engravings
of a piece of earth-moving equipment and
a cowboy on horseback look up and you'll
see towering sentinels of jack pine and
larch and beyond all along the horizon
the peaks of the cabinet mountains
a wild and spectacular range that
dominates the landscape around Libby but
is only a fingernail on the huge
outstretched hand of the Northern
Rockies many people came to add flowers
to walk among the crosses to read the
names some were carting long green
oxygen tanks by their sides like Don
kaeding who said cheerfully well my name
might be here next year it would be
pastor cam foot of the Troy Baptist
Church who played baseball with gala son
and at 35 has been diagnosed with
asbestosis conducted a short prayer
service then less read the list of
asbestos dead look at Libby look at the
scar of mining against the landscape
look at the working men's houses where
to this day tiny Spears of asbestos
hover in the air like a judges sentence
look at the people who walk to the post
office with slow shuffling steps rolling
what's left of their lives beside them
in the green tanks look at this piece of
ground filled with simple white crosses
and you can almost hear Maybelle Carter
and Johnny Cash singing one of lessons
favorite songs Undertaker Undertaker
Undertaker please drive slow for that
lady that's our Holland Lord I hate to
see her go what can I tell you about
this project
yeah how do you initially find out about
it well you know it was a kind of a
fluke and kind of not a fluke the way it
works seems like in journalism often
you're chasing one good story and one
story leads to another story and we had
been spending in the summer of nineteen
ninety nine we've been working for about
six months on a project on hard rock
mining and looking at mining on public
lands and and what sort of damage was
being done and and the fact that there
were billions of dollars in gold sort of
going out of the out of the nation's
public lands to too often to
multinational corporations so forth so
we've gone around the nine different
states in the West chasing the story in
Montana was the last one and we had a
photographer and two reporters in the
state and they happen to hear something
while they were working on the hardrock
story about another mine and up in libby
where the some people might be sick so i
get a call saying well it's a 200 mile
detour and it's not the story we came to
get but i want to go look at it so
thanks to Andy Schneider's persistence
he went and looked and the more he
looked the more just didn't seem right
we couldn't we couldn't believe that a
story of this size hadn't been reported
that nobody knew about it and the more
we looked at it the more we realized
that there had been an active conspiracy
of silence on the part of the companies
that random einen and people just as new
than in the little town and some of the
people who worked at the mine got sick
and nobody looked any farther than that
the medical community hadn't raised the
alarm so more we looked more we found
and it led us on on quite a chase
yeah 6,000 it's a mineral a you know in
this case it's it's what they call a
[ __ ] mineral or a contaminant of this
other or the the vermiculite is what
they were mining they weren't mining
asbestos they're reminding vermiculite
but in a lot of places just geologically
for Mickey light and tremolite asbestos
are found together and as a matter of
fact there is a form a queue light mind
going full-bore right now in Virginia
that is contaminated with asbestos it's
another little Libby happening right now
it just happens to be that way
geologically oh yeah so my question was
how they were able to keep it quiet for
so long winning the rest of the world in
1970 in the late 1970s in the rest of
the world is basis mines were closed but
I think you answer that by saying was
really a nickel at one well there's a
couple things to think about here one is
is in Libby itself the medical community
you know people who didn't even smoke
we're told that they were sick because
of smoking you know people who had
asbestos would get pneumonia every year
and they'd go into the hospital and they
be treated for their pneumonia and they
be sent home with no no diagnosis of the
underlying disease now the one thing in
the doctors favor is if you think about
it historically is at that time I wasn't
until people really understood what went
on in Libby that it was known that you
could contract asbestos-related disease
in this way I mean it's always thought
to be an occupational disease in other
words you have to work around it for a
long time to get to get the disease but
in Libby there were no changing
facilities at the mine there were no
showers so they the miners all came home
with dust on their clothes and the dust
was so toxic
that their wives and children got sick
and eventually there's just so much of
it all over the town that people who had
no connection to the mine got sick so
part of it was medical knowledge but the
fact is the medical community didn't
know what was going on in 1959 the owner
of the mine started an x-ray program
chest x-ray program of the miners and
they found lung abnormalities and 130
miners that first year nobody told the
miners the doctors in town didn't tell
the miners the company didn't tell him
and finally in the 80s one doctor tried
to blow the whistle and got run out of
town basically so that's part of it the
mine ownership was involved with the
hospital board and it was just all a
very sort of internal thing the other
part of it is the government that
basically didn't do its job both the
state government who discovered the
asbestos in the or in 1956 and wrote
reports that were confidential shown
only to the management of the mine in
the federal government the EPA in 1975
of the scotts company that makes Scotts
Turf Builder and so forth in Ohio they
were using at that time almost a quarter
of the total production of the libby
mine I had a huge operation there and
their workers started getting lung
disease started getting pleural effusion
bleeding the lungs and EPA actually came
in and did a study and discovered that
it was because of the or from Libby and
that the or from Libya was toxic and
contained asbestos and that report got
stuck in a file drawer and was not
discovered rediscovered until after the
p.i did the stories and the EPA send an
emergency response team out there almost
two decades later and that team started
looking in their own records and found
that their own agency had covered this
up and the one plausible explanation for
that is that in the in the early 80s
there was something called the grace
Commission which was a commission that
Ronald Reagan
set up it was a run by a bunch of
businessman specifically J Peter Grace
who also owned the grace corporation
that ran the mine but the grace grace
Commission was charged with getting
government off the backs of industry
so-called streamlining government making
government more efficient and less
intrusive and somewhere in that process
it got so untrue civ that nobody ever
did anything about the asbestos in Libby
yeah the town I mean as far as I mean I
wouldn't like I wouldn't want to move
there knowing that the history well you
know one of the obscene things about
this is it's one of the most beautiful
places imaginable one of the prettiest
places I've ever been on this planet
it's a beautiful spot but you're right i
mean it has definitely affected the town
and a lot of people are really bitter
about the publicity sort of a slave and
messenger situation where you know our
town was just fine until people started
nosing around in this of course their
people were dying of it but that was you
know they felt that that nobody should
have raised raised a fuss about it there
are a lot fewer of those people now
since since after we did the stories in
the p.i the federal government came in
and did did this survey and found that
if almost a third of the town has lung
abnormalities so that I think really
changed a lot of mines in town
well you know that it's an interesting
story because when three days after our
stories came out thank goodness for a
guy named Bill yellowtail who was then
the region eight EPA Administrator was a
rancher from loyola Montana Crow Indian
amazing guy anyway he was furious
because we quoted the EPA's state
coordinator as saying this was strictly
a personal hygiene problem on the part
of the miners he just went nuts and he
called in a top top EPA emergency scene
coordinator and a team of an
epidemiologist and and a public health
doctor and they came in and started
looking and and discovered the problem
and they thought that we were wrong I
thought it was a classic case of
journalists not knowing what they're
talking about and they found out that it
was actually worse than what we'd said
so that launched a clean up the
emergency part of which lasted about
three years and now they're into what's
called long-term remediation but they've
spent 40 million bucks so far but they
they're not even close to getting it all
cleaned up and now just like a lot of
Superfund sites in the country the
money's running out from the federal
government there's a lot of pressure
it's just like what's going on at
Hanford there's a lot of pressure cut
some corners clean it up quick quick and
dirty kind of an approach and so there's
there's a lot of people in Libby who
were fighting that trying to get the
government to pay more attention the
head of the administrator the EPA is
going to be in Libby next month and that
could be kind of an interesting visit
should be should be interesting to see
what happens
would have been the consequences for the
greatest company well and in April of
2001 they declared bankruptcy right
before that they bought a company called
sealed air corporation makes like FedEx
pouches and mailing packaging stuff
small company they transferred billions
of dollars in assets to seal their and
then they declared bankruptcy
fortunately the EPA has something called
forensic accountants who basically our
track polluters finances and they took
him to federal court in Missoula and it
looks like that they're going to get
some of that money I've accessed back to
some of that money but they're a lot of
people who filed lawsuits obviously
against grace right now there's
something in the in the Congress called
the asbestos Fairness Act I prefer to
think of it as the asbestos industry
relief act that basically would make it
a lot easier for for all companies
involved in asbestos to evade
responsibility for for part of it part
of the problem is the trial lawyers too
I mean there are a lot of frivolous
that's bestest suits out there what they
do is they run these screening clinics
and if you find a shadow in your lung
they sue everybody who ever made
asbestos and take a couple thousand
bucks and give it you know and and take
thirty percent of it or 40 so there's
been a lot of that and it's been an
abuse but the upshot of that is that a
lot of people who are truly sick and who
have had relatives die aren't getting
anything so it's big it's a big problem
and it's the shocking thing to me is how
widespread it still is most people don't
understand that asbestos is still
perfectly legal in this country it's
legal to manufacture it products
containing asbestos to import it
whatever there was an attempt at banning
it in the 90s and it under pressure from
industry it got overturned and the
government
didn't appeal it and so there is no band
on that's bestest in the country today
still asbestos and breaks most people
most mechanics most parts shop people
don't think there is there is I in a lot
of breaks some some not but there's
there isn't some and there's three
quarters of a million professional
mechanics out there and a lot of
backyard mechanics who are still at risk
we found asbestos we started testing
consumer products as part of this
investigation and we found to our horror
that there was s bestest in crayons
Crayolas a couple other brands of
american-made crayons we couldn't
believe it and we'd heard that there was
crate there's talc and crayons and we
knew there was s bestest and some talc
so we tested something we couldnt
believe the results so we retested came
up the same way so we wrote a story
saying there's s best o sin in crayons
and it was like a bomb went off as you
can imagine you know people talk about
slay the messenger people were really
upset with us too for raising the
possibility that their kids crayons
might have best best oh so but
nonetheless the first thing that
happened was the the industry issued a
statement saying there is no asbestos
and crayons no we haven't tested for it
because it's not there and then then
minion Smith owns Crayola hired a
so-called independent lab to to test the
crayons and they tested one crayon and
came back and said there was no asbestos
in it and then we wrote a story that
said that the lab they chose had made 7
million dollars testifying for the
asbestos industry so finally the
government stepped in we were really out
on the limb finally the government
stepped in after decades of doing
nothing on asbestos the Consumer Product
Safety Commission stepped in and did
some testing and found the same thing we
found and so within a week all the major
crayon manufacturers said we'll take it
out they did so we then tracked back to
try to figure out where it came from and
it wasn't a talc and it was all from a
talc mine in upper New York and
upstate New York called the Vanderbilt
talc company and they had been fighting
asbestosis regulation for for many years
and continued to fight and continue to
mind health there and miners are
continuing to die there so it's really
all over in society it's interesting
yeah it true that legislation has been
introduced to ban it though well um
patty Murray thankfully read our stories
in the API she has she has introduced a
writer on or enhances asbestos Fairness
Act that would ban but that would that
would be a ban I think its prospects for
passage are not great frankly I hope I
hope it passes but I don't think the
odds are very good in this Congress well
it's hard to say I mean it's certainly
some I think they're still wallboard
being made that has it the EPA has
tested various construction project
products and has has found it in some I
think the EPA's website probably has
some of that stuff listed I I think that
there is probably still semester soon
vermiculite products because I know give
you an example this mine in Virginia
grace used to own the property there and
they sold it because they did tests and
found out that the or was contaminated
asbestos they sold it to a guy who now
owns the mine is now mining it he's a
former assistant administrator of the
EPA he worked in the Nixon White House
he owns the mine for years and years the
mine safety and health administration
been doing inspections there and finding
nothing after some of our stories came
out the administrator of em Shaw under
Clinton called us up and said you know
our agencies should be disgraced for for
what happened in a shame for what
happened in Libya and what's happening
elsewhere and to make sure it never
happens again they sent a surprise team
of inspectors into that mine
found or up to ninety nine percent
asbestos in that mine they shut off some
areas of the mine they cited the mine
they they warned the miners told him to
wear protective gear they put warning
signs all over the place and on january
twentieth two thousand one the cones
came down the warning signs came down
and that mine is mine is progressing
full bore so I'd be very concerned about
products with that with vermiculite in
them lon lon products the big thing is
is to not expose yourself to the dust
not dump the bag out and and that sort
of thing the other the other real
concern consumer concern i think is the
old zona light insulation from libby is
in anywhere from 15 to 35 million homes
in the country it's loose fill
insulation it's in attics and it's it's
not going to hurt you if it's just in
your attic and it's not coming through
ceiling tile or anything if it's if it's
just in your attic but as soon as you
remodel as soon as the cable installer
goes up there as soon as you you do
anything that could disturb it it gets
in the air and it is very toxic it's a
big problem whenever a house like that
is demolished it's a problem so that's
something to really be aware of
especially if you have an older home is
Libya safer now than it was
I think so I mean they've done some some
good things for years and years there
were piles of vermiculite or downtown
and Libby and the kids would swing on
ropes and land in it you know it's like
a big sandbox and by you know the ice
rink at plumber school in Libby was it
was all vermiculite underneath the track
at the high school was made out of
vermiculite the ballfields had it all
over those things have been cleaned up
some of the other areas have been
cleaned up in town there are still a lot
of houses they gave the stuff away free
to people in town for for insulation and
for gardens and so it's just all over
the town as well as what came out of
they came in the air you know so there's
still a lot of houses that need to be
cleaned up and but most of the public
sites have been cleaned up they bury in
the ground or what yeah they do and they
bear head covered up I how didn't the
asbestos industry get all this political
power in the first place
like ticket just randomly they just pay
people off or I i think it's it's you
know a big piece of it take the Canadian
piece the big there's big ass' vessels
industry in Canada it's not that many
jobs but the thing is it's in Quebec and
so it's become a sort of been all
wrapped up in separatist politics in
Canada and so nobody wants to touch the
asbestos industry because it's it's just
basically a political sacred cow in this
country some of the major it's sort of
the big lie theory it's like if you're
big enough you can get away with it and
these couple of these companies are
enormous companies they've been very
successful johns-manville raybestos
dresser industries you know grace
certainly one of the biggest and the
list is it's a long list but it's
basically a list of it's a chunk of
corporate america and i think it's just
like any other situation in the
vanderbilt talc is a good example they
certainly had local senators and
congressmen doing their bidding because
it was a matter of jobs so question of
is the whole lobbying process whole
political process really it's a perfect
example of it but it is really an ugly
piece of American corporate history is
the Bush administration doing anything
to address this problem
the Clinton administration do anything
hurling to your dresser besides for your
time a decision yet well the answer is
no and almost nothing certainly the EPA
under Carol Browner and Clinton did not
cover itself with glory on asbestos
there are a lot of decisions that could
have been made that that that went the
wrong way there are one thing that I
certainly learned comes through in a
research we did for this there are some
wonderful people in the government there
are some very dedicated people who are
trying to protect the public safety
trying to do their jobs and they
basically are not only at war with the
polluters but they're at war with their
own higher ups and the agency in their
war with the administration certainly
things got worse after in the in the
current administration there's there's
just no denying that you know when 911
happened the levels of asbestos that
released in the air in lower Manhattan
are just incredible and 22 days after
911 Christy Whitman stood in New York
instead the air safe to breathe and
EPA's own research showed that it wasn't
he be a complete completely moon suit
workers the whole thing decontaminated
their own offices in Manhattan but
didn't do much for anybody else the if
you read it's hard not to get cynical if
you read EPA's reports on on a post 9-11
asbestos in Manhattan you read the
summary report you think everything is
pretty well handled and you read the
detail of the of the research and you
realize that the levels are very
dangerous and the journalism
follow up these kind of stories
because it seems like it's a public good
but you must have to do a lot of
research to get ones is it's it's what
we do and and it's it's this is the
great thing I mentioned the pies
commitment to this story I mean it's
it's sort of our responsibility to
attack these kinds of stories as well as
the more the easier that lower hanging
fruit that we get the paper every day
you know it it's important that we spend
some some resources and some time doing
this kind of kind of work being a
watchdog for the public interest and I
was very fortunate in this case to have
a wonderful reporter an indomitable
reporter would not take no for an answer
on this story and having that kind of
expertise and being able to have a
commitment to the story is just what it
takes
I was just going to ask not everyone in
Libby has asked best ptosis who does
have it who's most susceptible to it
well the thing is nobody knows when the
incidence of asbestosis in Libya is even
going to peek a the latency period of
the disease is so long that as part of
the reason that companies can evade
responsibility it's part of the reason
you know that that it went unnoticed for
so long or unreported for so long in
libya's because it's an old person's
disease I mean often people who get it
are in their 60s 70s but it is a truly
horrible way to die and a very expensive
way to die so it's hard to say how many
people will get it as I say that there
are somewhere between eighteen hundred
two thousand people who have been
diagnosed with lung abnormality in Libby
there may be more down the road because
there's still an exposure and that's
what frightens a lot of people who were
there looking at it the other thing is
that that the screening is really a
double-edged sword because once people
have gone through that screening they
can't get insurance if they if they are
found to have that it really affects
their ability good insurance and so
there's this huge almost incalculable
unfunded medical situation in Libya and
will be for many years plans not that
I'm aware of no
I would you compare like the political
power of the asbestos industry to the
tobacco companies and the oil companies
in terms of special interest groups in
the government or use a very parallel
comparison think it's a very apt
comparison but in terms of what's bigger
it's all its I think it's wrong all of a
piece it's the same process so they're
similar in terms of their power in the
government is the media doing his job on
this beyond the I mean um some certainly
have you know Spokane after we did this
story the the Spokane papers followed up
as a wonderful reporter in Spokane and
spent a lot of time on this story there
are others the New York Times has been
strangely silent on this story but
others have have done a good job with it
and I think will probably continue to
sign in your book all right thank you
very much David McCumber is managing
editor of the Seattle post-intelligencer
an air that kills is published by GP
putnam's sons an imprint of the penguin
group visit penguin calm for more
information
[Music]